for the people of south sudan
survival is the business of everyday
life
hunger is ever present in this fragile
country
and war a constant threat but a new
worry
now jostles for their attention
coronavirus is spreading
and they've been told to take care and
the public
have been offered a vaccine but few here
are willing to take it the vaccine is
dangerous
yeah it can make somebody here you think
it might hurt you
yeah yeah so many fear yeah so many
people fear so many people are scared
to take the vaccine do you think uh
virus won't affect you
oh it's not affecting me why is that
because we are black people and i don't
feel like even taking the
vaccination of prana why is that i'm
just good
because god is powerful i only believe
in god the pandemic
is widely described as a global event
but that doesn't mean much in the kanye
kanye market
in fact i think i'm the only person here
who's wearing a mask
and the vaccine well for most people
that's
far more trouble than it's worth fear
and mistrust dominate here in the
country's capital
juba and a shipment of 132
000 cost-free vaccines has generated
very little interest this the scene at
juba central hospital
where they've erected a special walk-in
clinic
we try to motivate people to come
he's also a leader of the community
but some people say they didn't need to
be forced
if they don't act soon they'll miss
their chance
there are plenty of vaccines available
only 7
000 have been used but they're set to
expire in
mid-july and the majority may go to
waste
we found the hospital director trying to
sign people up
and everybody is welcome everybody in
google who want to be vaccinated
so this is the story go and tell the
world i tell my people first
you guys are so lucky to have the
vaccine here
he's asked foreign nationals to come
along to promote their effectiveness
so we joined ethiopians ugandans and
pakistanis in the queue
a vaccine in south sudan
still dr marker is unlikely to use up
his allocation
if tens of thousands of vaccines expire
you may have trouble getting another
batch
from kovacs absolutely it is a disaster
if this vaccine expire and then we have
a wave of
copper 19 killing our people and they
have the chance to come and get
fascinated
vaccine coverage across the african
continent
is extremely low here in south africa
the vaccine rollout has barely started
while in kenya
they're struggling to secure supplies
convincing people to take one will be
key
we spoke to an anxious sounding police
officer
in johannesburg how are you feeling a
bit nervous
okay and now what do you what are you
feeling nervous about
um you know there's a lot of things
that have been said about the vaccine
turns people into zombies and all that
few here object
to vaccinating children but it's harder
to get adults
in the booth people are understanding
and committed to childhood vaccines
i think the difference here is that
we're trying to target suddenly
a different population we're targeting
adults and
in this case very often older adults
people over 60 in many settings
might never have had a vaccine before
might well be
scared of the vaccine might not see the
necessity to have a vaccine having got
to that age
without a vaccine without an
adequate supply of vaccines african
countries
are vulnerable but they face a bigger
challenge in countries like south sudan
they need their citizens consent john
sparks
sky news in juba